removal out of focus there folks
hello how's everybody doing
I hope you're doing fine today I'm gonna
be continuing with geometry but before I
do I want to cover a little topic that
came up during the week related to
extinction extinction of man I was
dealing with that subject before and I
want to make sure that you know some
some of these loose ends are tied that
we cover them people understand what the
answers to those are has to do with the
issue of war and that's been lately on a
lot of people's minds so they brought
the issue of war and weather how that
relates to extinction I mean if we have
world war 92 99 percent of the people
get wiped out some people survive let's
assume that right well there are several
things do they engage in trade and save
themselves the today first of all do
they survive because everybody thinks
he's going to survive not the other guy
you know I'm always going to survive not
you okay and then the other question is
whether we're going to reproduce
population crashed and now we just start
all over again you know Adam and Eve and
you know people are not aware that
tradin has not always saved us and
here's a little listing of some of the
russian famines they had throughout the
history these are the documented ones
from 11 27 to the 1303 at least eleven
famine years were recorded for different
reasons you know like I show there at
the bottom could be draw mismanagement
politics sometimes it was deliberate to
get rid of some people that you didn't
want
another great famine no thirteen fifteen
to seventeen two million people a third
of population allegedly died eighteen
ninety one ninety two half-a-million
people famous one that is thrown against
the communists thousand five million
allegedly died in the twenty two twenty
two nineteen twenty two nineteen twenty
two years trade has not always stepped
in to save the day and the other thing
is these people had money under her hand
I mean they weren't rot rich but they
had money and so what I mean you know
they had money but no food and so you
know money does not equate to food
imagine if there is a world war right
and a lot of the transportation or the
routes or whatever are going to be
disrupted okay so it doesn't mean that
you have you might even have access you
might have a million dollars in your
house for all I know it doesn't mean you
have access to food so this notion that
people say that all just trade and I'll
trade my car for a banana may not happen
you may not have a banana to trade with
someone for anyways I like the dillons
words Bob Dylan for those of you who
heard of him and he he kind of
synthesizes what I'm saying here he says
in his song talking World War three
blues he says hey I've been having that
same old green the same old dreams I
dreamt that the only person left after
the war was made everybody thinks he's
gonna serve right right I didn't see you
around in his dream everybody's having
them dreams everybody sees itself
walking around with nobody else yeah and
he also answers the other question that
I just raised the about Adam and Eve in
the same song and he says I spied a girl
on before she could leave I said let's
go and play Adam and he
I took her by the hand and my heart it
was thumpin when she said hey man you
crazy or something
you see you seen what happened last time
they started so you know I don't think
the girls so they are gonna have kids
after after a war world war if that's
what what happened I'm saying it's gonna
crash and if it crashes and I mean
populations got crashing population
crashes to say 1% of humanity no the
girls are not gonna restart the race
forget about that they're just go about
their lives and yeah you know it's one
of those things that you really get a
ponder all these issues people think
they're gonna survive first they think
they're going to trade for food
specially or they're gonna go in and say
hey you know I'm gonna carve a niche in
this trade business in this food market
that just sprung up I'm gonna make
millions and I don't think money will be
worth anything after a world war if a
war came came to that but we don't need
a war but the other thing about war that
you should be aware of if if there is a
world war is an economic issue why do we
want why do we fight why do we battle
you know we we do war because of
resources okay influence Betsey over
those who have resources and the
ultimate resource of any animal is food
that's it you know that's you need food
you need to secure you don't need to go
to another country and steal their
telephones or their TVs you need food
that you do need okay and so you know
what is for food ultimately and in
fighting in any species you know most of
the in fighters for the gals right the
two birds fight for the gals but there's
also a fight for food okay
there's always a struggle for food so
keep that in mind
food is unavoidable in extinction
theories you can
avoided people will say well you know
that doesn't apply to us well you'll
find out you're an animal and you do
need food okay and the only other thing
I should mention about that is you know
that
Calhoun's theory you know he he carried
out experiments with mice and rats and
his utopian experiments always ended up
in extinction and once the population
crashed the colony did not reproduce
again and wasn't only them
you also had a you know an experiment
wasn't really an experiment it was like
they were trying to do save some deers
and he put them on st. Matthews Island
and there they crashed you know they
they lived like nineteen years and well
the numbers started coming down to it's
nothing stopping them
they didn't reproduce and start coming
back up but ya know they went down all
the way extinction they were able to
save the last twenty I think and what
are those who was you know there was
only one meal young male that was the
only male all the others are females I
guess women survive more than men Nicky
they can take it we can't anyways I was
dealing with geometry and let me just
summarize what I said last Wednesday
last time it goes something like this
geometry is the study of shapes and
sizes okay that's what that's how it's
defined and yeah people would like to
redefine that some some people out there
would like to do that because it
destroys their religion that's the only
reason yeah geometry you need to have a
shape a size in front of you that's your
shape right no shape no geometry and
that's the starting but you have to have
something in front of you okay and
people don't like to think about that
because they think they can do it in the
abstract mode just talk about perimeters
or whatever now you need the shape you
need some kind of physical object inside
there the
itinerary the perimeter is simply you
tracing that shape and mathematicians
who are already gone their minds
completely blown they don't want to
think in those terms they want they want
to think in completely in abstract terms
they say hey you know yeah I don't I
don't need the shakes any more like
youth-led okay so but these are people
who I've gone outside
anyways geometry is the foundation of
mathematical physics okay
mathematical physics stands on geometry
everyone claims that the point is the
building block of geometry okay so the
point is very important because you know
it's the bread and butter of geometry
you can't do anything without the point
or without mentioning the word point
Greeks discovered that by the way but
everyone casually confesses and they
that they can't define the strategic
word point nobody knows what a point is
they're staring at it right in front of
you and they don't know what it is they
said oh man I can't define it
everyone illustrates a smudge that has
width and height okay but then they say
that you're staring us despite staring
is a 2d dot the theorist tells you that
the point that is in front of your eyes
has no size volume dimensions or shape
so we have we start out at a tremendous
contradiction in geometry and that's our
starting point so that's the quicksand
on which all of geometry is founded is
based on this undefined point this thing
that they can't define which is staring
at them in their faces and it's a 2d
little dot and they say well the dots
not the point
well then why did you cut the point in
there if that dot is not the point
take the thought out of there what is a
point well they want to give you the
idea the notion that it's a location but
if if the point is a location and has no
place in geometry because geometry is
the study of shapes what kind of shape
is a point if it has no dimensions no
sighs new length width or height no no
no volume okay so that's the starting
point we start out on the wrong foot
with the point we have no definition we
don't know what a point is even though
we're staring at it we don't know what
that thing is it's like staring at a
tree and saying I don't know what a tree
is
okay okay so these are some of the
comments I got I'm gonna go through the
comments show why we're still having
problems with the point I don't know if
people have problem understanding what
I'm telling them the context that I'm
presenting they keep going back to what
they were taught in high school in
college and they say I don't know but
this is easy see a point is and what is
a point let's see and here we have one
fella says there are two separate issues
of the word point that I can that I
encountered eight okay a point variable
in video game or code is location okay
so point is location great we're on top
do you need problem there's the
locations has nothing to do with
geometry okay because you need an object
and locations not a physical object
locations or concept but let's continue
referenced by Cartesian coordinates
Cartesian coordinates one of those you
mean Cartesian number lines no such
thing is a coordinate in mathematics
there's no such thing as the dimension
in mathematics mathematics has no use
whatsoever for length width or height
those are qualitative notions that
mathematics has absolutely no use for it
never does use and so they dismiss that
saying well that's the informal
definition of dimensions or notion of
dimensions no no well let's get it
straight mathematicians don't use
dimensions coordinates or vectors okay
I'll get to that in in the future but
none of those belong to mathematics
mathematics only has number lines and
they call those number lines
alternatively right dimensions
coordinates and vectors
but mathematics has no place for these
qualitative notions they just have room
for number lines and that's what they've
been always always been dealing with
okay okay the size of a point is equal
to the square or cube of the smallest
possible unit length in the game so we
got a little bit of a contradiction here
he started saying and it's a location
okay now he says it's a cube he's
talking about smallest length well aside
from the fact that I can imagine you
know a smaller length and you can
anytime you want just give me any length
that you want then chop it up as much as
make it as small as you want I'll cut it
didn't happen and beat you I'll make it
smaller and I can go the other direction
too you imagine the biggest length you
can imagine I'll double it so I don't
know what a small length means it has no
sense in physics I don't know if it has
any notion you know any sense in
mathematics okay so the point a location
or a cube I mean I don't know judging by
what I see there right what is the size
of a location I mean is this 0.05
millimeter cube is is that the size of a
location I mean you know what is it are
we talking about location are we talking
about a physical object and this is the
problem they go back and forth they
don't even realize that they're doing
this now this for them this is normal
they say oh yeah see it's it's a
location I can locate it with two
Cartesian coordinates or three or ten or
whatever and and and that's the location
of this box and the box is the point but
the point is also this Cartesian
coordinate system the location so are we
talking about structure are we talking
about the location and they don't seem
too real they go around in circles they
never never see this they've been so
brainwashed by for in high school and
college that they don't even ponder
these things anymore okay and so here it
is definition number two that this fella
is proposing
that nellyville' smallest needed unit
uplink so he's talking about smallest
length okay that's that's the notion
he's introducing here and he says take
it out you can slice it okay
this would make cubes points of L so now
we have again smallest length what's
that got to do with a cube and you clear
any cube okay which is a point right as
triple zero and label the rest in the
cordon that's a point
so the point the triple zero the
location I guess is a three numbers I
get three numbers and I have a point is
that what it is or the point of box what
is a point according to all this stuff
and so if we're cutting carrots the
point is very large but if we're mincing
carrots the point is very small uh-huh
so apparently the point that has
something to do with an object is that
what he what he's saying here are we
talking about an object and saying that
if we take a tip of a carrot we got a
point is that is that the notion here
and then just to finish off in both
definition the point is a counting
reference so yeah at this point judging
by all that I have no idea what a point
is because I still don't know if it's a
location a bunch of numbers a box a cube
what is a point yeah you got to define
the point and then you can't say well I
can't define a point because I don't
know what a point is but let me use the
word and I'm going to use it as
everything I'm gonna use it as the box
and I'm going to use it as also the
coordinate system that locates the box
somewhere so we got a problem we got a
serious problem here
okay and another comment here from
another fella says so the notion of a
point would assume a granularity what
we're talking about a physical object if
you talk about granular something I
guess you're talking about an object
some kind of bead a little seed maybe is
that a point
if there's an absolute coordinate system
and location can be quantized points
middles and so on exist
by definition well aside from the fact
that here's an understand what the word
exists means you can't apply it to
concepts such as points middles and
someone and quantized whatever aside
from that we got a problem because if we
got a coordinate system talking and
talking about location how does that
square off with granularity we got a
problem here these people can't seem to
tell the difference between an elephant
and where the elephant is located in
Africa those are two different things
and if these people don't realize that
so they put the two concepts into one
and they say well it's both it's the
elephant that's the location of the
elephant are both the point and also the
mass of the elephant just in case a
location within the elephant the center
of mass or whatever okay it's a concept
doesn't matter anything that's real it
better not because no concept can be
said to be real concepts the word real
here is used in ordinary speech and not
in a scientific language your concepts
do not exist concepts are not real only
objects can be said to exist and to be
real and that's where again you know
people I have to learn the language of
science before trying to define these
terms because they gotta start at square
one you got to know what a definition is
how to define words scientifically and
they haven't learned how to do that okay
okay another comment this one I liked
the most and talks about this as a
modern formulation of geometry talking
about geometry but shapes and sizes okay
it is done through set theory set theory
but is it TV sets what kind of set
theory is this and what he talks about
he says natural numbers rational numbers
real numbers what is a numbers what
those numbers have to do with geometry
with shapes and sizes you know one size
is bigger than another that's it that's
all
need to know in geometry right or do we
need to know anything else and for sure
we need a shape and these guys have
noticed that so what is a set well let's
see let's find out
look it up in the dictionary keep it
says mathematical logic that study sets
which is informed me which informally
are collections of objects so a set is a
collection of objects what that has to
do with geometry I have no idea so how
set theory relates to it so far I can't
figure out there are relevance of
mathematics collection of arms in the
language of set theory can be used that
you find nearly all mathematical objects
a mathematical object is an abstract
object or arising in mathematics in
mathematical practice an object is
anything that has been or could be
firmly defined okay let's see what kind
of mathematical objects these people
propose as examples okay and as what
you'll find
also from the wikipedia says numbers
integers permutations the only one I
like out of all these are is that one
that says derangement I think there's a
lot of the arrangement in mathematics
especially in in geometry okay
sets functions points lines polygons you
know what is all that and and so and
what does any of that have to do with
geometry that's the other issue that you
know makes you kind of wonder about
these people so where does that take us
well here's a part of that idea that
these people have and that's that we
have an n-tuple
that's what a point is a free number
system okay so says just a point is just
an n-tuple
XY and z so it's a three numbers that's
what a point is
or are we talking about a location or
are we talking about what's in that
location okay so so these are the things
that people have to settle and and they
have not been able to you know resolve
these issues after all these years okay
let's continue here where did we get all
this stuff let me get this thing out
where did we get all this stuff well we
got it like I said the other day we got
it from mr. Euclid okay and see if we
can get him here so many of these
sometimes can't find him
and you-let's in his book elements he
said a point is that which has no part
okay
and he said the end of the lines are
points so where did he get this well he
he was the first one to formulate this
remember he came a little after
Aristotle and Aristotle already put that
in his book if you look at six books of
physics from Aristotle he says the
extremities of two points can either be
one can neither be one nor together and
he puts under in in parentheses there
that which has no parts so what were
they talking about well they were both
of them they were talking about the atom
okay because that which has no part was
just what was an indivisible okay and
that indivisible was Democritus or
Lucifer's that's the indivisible so
whenever they use them they'll turn
indivisible the referring to that what
were they talking about the Aristotle
here well Aristotle got this notion that
he had to explain continuity okay and
the problem there is that he starts
using the point explain continuity but
he brings in subject matter that has
nothing to do with geometry
or it has to do with geometry only
tangentially okay so he uses length he
brings in the word length he brings in
the word time okay he says again if
length and time could have could thus be
compose up indivisible meaning the atom
right meaning the point okay because
they're they're talking about a point
that is indivisible
okay that's that's what these people had
in mind as far as the atom and how the
rule is structured out there so they
could be divided into indivisible since
each is divisible into the parts of
which it is composed
no continuous thing is divisible into
things without parts yeah nor can there
be anything of any other kind
intermediate between the parts or
between the moments now he turns the
brains in time so we're talking about
parts which means an object okay and
we're talking about moments and as you
can see at the end there without going
through all this you can see introduces
also magnitude and motion so we're
talking about like four different things
that or different concepts that
Aristotle introduces in this book and
this is going to be the foundation of
not only of Euclid's geometry but what
we have today in fact all this has to do
with what we have today we're using
magnitudes we talk about time you talk
about motion and we talk about the
individuals which we discovered was
divisible if I mean if we were talking
about the atom right but it says up
there it is plane that everything
continues is divisible into divisible
z-- what is he talking about he's saying
if you look at those boxes that I do
they're the tubes the last one has parts
to it he says you absolutely need to
have each one of these boxes made of
something in other words they have to be
divisible as well because otherwise
you're going to have what he says then
we're gonna have an indivisible in
contact with another indivisible one
atom in contact with another and then
they cannot be continuous you have to be
able to break that one up as well and so
he was a
the challenging Democritus with this
notion of continuity okay get this here
and well again you know if you look at
my point I don't know what they're
talking about because my point shows
that point has height and width okay
that's my point because that's what I
see in front that's objectively what's
in front of me without having to
second-guess anyone that's straight
forward
yeah but again what Aristotle was trying
to do he was trying to challenge the
notion of the atomic notion okay and he
says he was talking about continuity but
then he uses the word continuity in
several different ways he uses it for
structure like a continuous structure he
uses it for time he uses it for motion
what is he referring to if you go
through that whole book book number six
has several sections to it it's a big
mumbo jumbo he keeps giving examples of
introducing examples that constantly
change on you maybe he's talking about
structure suddenly he jumps into time
and then he jumps into motion and back
to structure and so yes very confusing
because the examples he gives shows that
he's rambling that's what he's doing
he's just he doesn't have his thoughts
straight and we've been heritage this
notion of continuity that were
continuous from him essentially this is
the notion we find in the dictionary
today uninterrupted in time is that
where continuous means I thought
continues was an adjective see you can
see a table is continuous but if you're
not talking about time or without
cessation which we first emotion you
know that's incessant you never say that
a table is incessant unless it's moving
right incessantly
no motion can be said to be incessant
but that's different than saying that a
table is incessant know it take was
continuous if anything right and motion
is incessant and these people have used
the word continues always to qualify
motion as you see there uninterrupted in
time without cessation that comes from
Aristotle because he's he's the guy that
comes up with these notions to begin
with or at least one of the first one
maybe there was someone before him right
and said being an immediate connection
or spatial relationship okay continue a
series of blasts or a continuous row of
warehouses again a series of blasts
that's not continues that's those are
not objects those are phenomena you can
say one right after another that's got
to do with time and motion and
continuous row of warehouses
that's not continuous either because
what you're doing is chopping up each
house and you're putting them together
like if even if they're touching the
surface the surface okay if you do that
do you have a continuous row of houses
no you have discrete houses comprising
this this elongated thing okay and
that's what Aristotle was referring to
he was saying that you build the
continues with these divisible 's and
that sounds so terrible at Prezi for
physics okay so bear with me a minute
I'm gonna get to that let me just say
that here they built from that the
notion that we have today of space-time
okay and that's the continuum
okay the continuum is a in other words
they turned the adjective and they
turned it into a noun okay we went from
continuous the adjective which is
applied to verbs to motion to time and
now they're gonna take that word and
they're gonna apply it to the Internet
this adjective it to a nowadays continue
a series of elements or items that
by such tiny differences that they do
not seem to differ from each other okay
an example of a continuum is a range of
temperatures hey continuous whole
quantity or series thing whose parts
cannot be separated or separately
discerned okay so they're turning this
adjective into a thing and what do they
end up with all that you know you can go
through the rest of the definitions
there but what do they end up with all
that well they end up with this monster
here which they call space-time okay and
you can see that you know this is you'll
find this on unisys spacetime is a
mathematical model that joins space and
time into a single idea called a
continuum they also refer to it as a
manifold what as a manifold will the
matter phones our continuum what did you
understand
so what you're staring at that
four-dimensional continuum right it is
known as a min Koski space so space is
continuous or continuum I guess it's a
physical objects a manifold so they turn
this you know what does it made are made
of events what does any event a point in
space-time so there we get the point
back again it's all circular okay
it all comes down to the point what is
the point of point is a what is an event
of an event is a point in space that you
take all these points and you build a
continuum and the question is you know
at this point once you look at what
Aristotle proposed with all these
notions regarding the point and how it
fits into this notion of continuum
especially the continuous line and his
notion was that if you chop it up you're
going to get all these points and each
one of those points got to be divisible
as well otherwise you know you don't
have a continuum okay and that's his
notion well you're the questions for you
this is for homework okay anyone who
wants to take this on okay and here it
is these are the questions for you let
me put this back up
here and so the question is you know is
continued made of points or is it a
single piece okay are we talking about
something made of discrete parts of
segments or are we talking about
something that is made of a single piece
across whether a line or a point you
know because again what Aristotle is
saying is that that point there is also
it should be made of parts otherwise he
can't build a continuing such as the
line below that's what he's saying
and remember these notions are the ones
that were inherited by the mathematical
physicists okay and that's these are the
notions that we have today in geometry
okay here's another question you know
again are we talking about continuous
movement are we talking about motion or
a continued structure what does the word
continue is referred to is it an
adjective or an adverb see continuous as
far as I know is an adjective and you
can use it to qualify structure
architecture or whatever bodies but you
can't use it to say continuous motion
not in not in science you can use that
in in ordinary speech in non scientific
language but you can't use the word
continues to qualify motion now the word
is incessant and incessant for the
purposes of physics is an adverb not an
adjective incessant can only qualify
motion and so the point if it moves like
it's moving up there then you can say
it's moving incessantly or its incessant
motion if you want to use that term but
you can't say it's continuous motion
continuous only refers to the structure
science again for the physics versus
ordinary speech and so what the
mathematicians are using here and have
been for 2,000 years is ordinary speech
in formal language and language that has
not been defined by the way
okay here's another one also dealing
with continuity but the questions are is
our dot our point is a 2d or 3d you know
is it an abstract abstraction is it or
is it physical are we talking about the
real world because if it's not part of
the real world what are we using points
for and how are we relating the points
the abstract points to the real world
that's the issue you know so the the
question here you've got 3d balls at the
bottom and 2d plates
dots at the top what is the point is it
two DS a 3d is it the in here's well
here's more there's another one also
dealing with continuity by the way are
we talking about continuous numbers the
number line real numbers or natural
numbers or whatever or are we dealing
with dots are we dealing with balls
plates dots you know whatever
what does continuous referred to and
what does the point refer to is the
point a number is that what a point is
are we just going to use the point and
say the not only location but are we
just going to give a number to a point
and say well that's that's point number
five is that what a point is a number
and or are we gonna put a dot are we
gonna put a little ball you know these
you can't
the problem is that they put all these
notions into the same word point that's
the problem
and so people don't realize that the
word point means all these things for a
mathematician because on the one hand
he's talking in abstract mode but on the
other he wants to make sure that you
understand that he's he can to scroll
with his points were his numbers with
with his equations that he can describe
the real world out there so he does want
to relate it to the physical world
otherwise what's the purpose of math
just an abstract discipline with no
relation to read
reality no he's got to try to link it to
reality he's got to try to link it the
physics ergo you know mathematical
physics they have to tie the knot
between physics and mathematics and
again geometry is that you know that
connection geometry is the point of
connection and again what they've done
is mix concepts with objects the object
is the thought and the concept in this
case is the the numbers but then you
know you also have concepts such as
location and location is not what you
thought location is not in mathematics
location is a set of number lines not
coordinates not dimensions but number
lines that allow you to tell how far
something is from something else that's
all it is
it's just a bunch of number lines so
don't call them coordinates it's the
wrong word to use no coordinates in
mathematics ok and here's another
question for you again locations are
numbers what is a what is a dot or a
point is it a number or is it a location
which one is it you know this is these
are things people have to don't realize
that that is in front of them and for as
much as I talk it's like many people
just don't get it because they've been
so conditioned to use that nice word
they've been conditioned in high school
and college to think of these things you
know as as no problem they don't see a
problem with all this location numbers
dots put them all together yeah it's
it's everything it's I like to say that
the word point is the god of mathematics
truly is ok because it's more powerful
than God coin can do anything ok so are
we talking about the distance traveled
or are we talking about a separation
between two points for example when you
look at a line right which we're going
to look at for drawn you get a line and
they say
the two end points are points right okay
the two things that clog the ends of
this line are points so are we talking
about two dots that are separated by
some distance or are we talking about
1.1 thing concentrated into a location
and that location moving all the way to
the other side so are we talking about
one object or two objects is it one
object that is moving or is it
separation between two objects you know
all these questions are things that
mathematicians have not resolved because
they're all qualitative and they don't
deal with qualitative stuff they do only
with quantitative stuff so they just
bypass all this stuff but the problem is
then they make inferences about the real
world about the world out there from all
these abstractions and they claim they
have proven them because they've proven
it mathematically not because they
proven it in any way out there with some
kind of I mean how do you prove an
invisible entity the existence of an
invisible entity such as a photon what
do you do you gonna bring it to me and
show me and say see I proven it you
can't see it you can't touch it you know
whatever the mechanism is there right
the the mediator the agent you can't
touch that you can't see it but you say
you prove that it and you proven it
mathematically with an equation these
are the issues and here's another one
again for those who wish to take it as
homework okay seconds or meters are we
talking about time or are we talking
about something you're going to measure
like with a ruler you know what is this
dot that is moving is it is it moving
according to time are we gonna time it
in measured in seconds or are we gonna
measure in meters you know so we've got
all these issues where these things are
not clarified to it or better yet what
happens they've included all these
into one that's the problem so they get
away with murder because they can jump
from one motion from one notion to
another without any problem because
they've already included all these
notions inside the point and what the
point does because they're going to get
into a line the line is going to be
continuous and what do they mean by
continuous that it stopped up in two
points and so this is my definition
continuous a hypothetical object made of
a single piece that's what it means in
physics
that's what continuous means it's an
adjective if you want to qualify motion
you've got to use the other word
incessant that's not my definition but
I'll accept that it's the definition
you'll find in the dictionary continuing
without interruptions ceaseless unending
not unending if we're talking about
structure okay an ending only if you're
talking about motion but ceaseless
incessant incessantly those are the
words are perpetual those words refer to
motion okay whereas continues you know
refers to objects and a similar notion
which I'll probably cover in in a future
is the word straight straight as an
adjective you can apply it only to
objects right to linear ly is what you
apply to motion so we got a
distinguished adjectives from adverbs
and mathematicians have a hard time with
that because they constantly use
adjectives to qualify motion and that's
okay in ordinary speech not in
scientific language okay anyways I'll be
continuing with this line of questioning
and wondering about geometry appreciated
foundations of geometry I'll be dealing
with that next time around
what is it Sunday and I just want to
make sure that people understand what
the the problem what the issues are that
I'm trying to get through and that is
that the
what they've done with a point is put
lots of concepts into one and the first
one starts with the point itself is it a
thought that you're staring at which is
objectively in front of you or is it a
location that's the first but then it
doesn't stop there then they say well
it's a location but we don't care about
the location like the physical location
of the earth in the universe you know
you say ok it's the distance to every
object in the universe that's not their
notion what they do is put a frame of
reference and they say well you know
what we have is you know it's like
finding the treasure chest - the
treasure chest well 10 feet this way
five feet that way and three uploads the
mountain and you'll find the treasure
chest that's what a point is to them
it's the point it's not the point but
it's how to get there it's you know so
this notion about position which is very
close to the word point you know is is
it's just a way to get their even
position is a dynamic concept in in
mathematics you know you take five along
the X and three along the Y and reach
the point and so you put the X Y and
then you get five three and that's the
point
the point of what do you mean the point
the point is two numbers yeah it's an
ordered pair what do you mean by that I
need two coordinates to get there so all
these concepts have been rolled into one
we'll go again and again when you say
well what does that have to do with
geometry okay so that's one issue the
other one is the this notion that
Aristotle raises which is crucial for
the point as well which is continuity
you know that we need the point to to
explain continuity and why did he
introduce that because he's gonna go
into line and the line is not what you
thought the line is a line is an
itinerary in mathematics there is no
such thing as a line mathematics has no
use or geometry has no use for a
not mothered you the real geometry does
but but fake the geometry which is what
these people do they're talking about
itineraries always trajectories so when
they talk about line it's not a line
it's not a geometric line it's it's an
itinerary you're going to be measuring
something you're gonna unroll the
measuring tape okay so so keep that in
mind when they talk about line it's not
a line it's an itinerary
what is the itinerary made of what is
that motion made of locations what is
the location a point so we have all
these points making up locations right
making up motion and that's what
mathematics deals with and they call the
location they call it a point and the
light and airy they call a line and
people get confused because they say
well hold it a point is that guy in line
is that little elongated thing that you
drew on the board well yeah that's just
a pictorial representation of a line
then what do you mean by lying well the
line is really the itinerary it's the
motion
it's the unrolling of the measuring tape
because what we're going to be doing is
measuring that's what geometry is about
they claim and that's the foundation of
mathematical physics so I just want to
make sure you understand the main points
that I'm trying to get across and I'm
not sure everybody does get it because
they've been so conditioned by what
they've been taught in high school in
mathematics and college some of these
people showed there where they just
reproduce and say yeah see it's a it's a
little cube and it's also the location
of the cube here's the coordinate system
so you know which is the point okay so
we'll see you on Sunday and I'm going to
continue with geometry so if you are
interested in learning a little more
about what lines are we're gonna get
into planes dimensions and we're gonna
have a little bit of fun here okay we'll
see you on Sunday bye bye